okay Donald Trump last week announced
that he would be giving a another border
wall speech on Saturday at 3 p.m.
Eastern Time it ultimately got pushed
back an hour and it ended up happening
just after 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time from
the Oval Office on Saturday and it was
being previewed as this big compromise
that Donald Trump was going to offer
Trump was ready to deal and give this
fantastic set of parameters to Democrats
to get government reopened of course
including funding for his border wall
remember the government shutdown that is
still going on is over the border wall
Donald Trump effectively throwing a
temper tantrum he already gave one
speech where he claimed that we have an
immigration crisis the solution to which
lies solely in a 5.7 billion dollar
partial border wall I'm not going to
play the speech for you you can find it
online easily and what I want to do
instead is just get into the analysis of
what was said but quite frankly another
reason not to play the speech is that it
was a repetition mostly of the things
that Donald Trump said in the first one
all of which the the ones that required
debunking we already debunked and
missing from the entire thing just like
last time was a discussion of the fact
that Trump promised that Mexico is going
to pay for the wall that's totally
utterly obviously off the table now and
it's not even being mentioned in these
discussions of the wall even though
Trump told us endless times Mexico is
going to pay for that wall Donald Trump
did repeat during the border wall speech
number two that quote drugs are coming
over the border and the wall is going to
fix it obviously that's a lie most of
the drugs coming from Mexico aren't
crossing anywhere where we would have a
border wall they're crossing through
ports of entry and of course most drugs
in the United States aren't coming over
the border at all Donald Trump repeated
once again the lie that undocumented
immigration holds wages down I've talked
about this before the corporation's who
are hiring undocumented immigrants are
to blame for any
impact on wages which by all accounts is
extraordinarily modest but the real
problem is that the corporations aren't
being punished for hiring undocumented
immigrants and the undocumented
immigrants are being scapegoated there
i've already widely talked about that i
won't spend a lot of time on it today
but Donald Trump's proposal and offered
to Democrats is what I want to focus in
on Donald Trump wants to begin with
number one 800 million dollars in
humanitarian aid number two 805 million
dollars in drug detection 2,750
additional border agents and law
enforcement new hires 75 judge teams for
immigration courts and of course 5.7
billion dollars for what he is now
calling a steel barrier along 230 miles
of border amazingly during this speech
Donald Trump actually said you know we
don't really need a border wall across
the entire border because there are some
natural barriers like bodies of water
which of course is exactly what we've
been saying for years at this point
Trump isn't actually realizing that he
doesn't want that full border wall he is
realizing that he's just not gonna get a
win on the entire border wall so now
he's pretending he never really wanted
the whole border wall anyway absolutely
unbelievable that the goal posts are
being moved in this way now what is
Donald Trump willing to offer Democrats
if they give him the 5.7 billion in
order to get government reopened Trump
is willing to give number-one an asylum
application process that would take
place in countries of origin okay this
is a big deal because there's this
discussion over
people are coming in these caravans to
the border and and they're coming over
illegally except no they're not they're
actually going to the border to request
asylum because there's no process for
doing that in their country of origin
Donald Trump is offering to create an
application process for asylum where
people can do it in their country of
origin and Donald Trump is offering
three
years of relief for daca recipients
during which they would know that they
don't risk deportation and a three year
extension on what's called TPS temporary
protected status for some undocumented
immigrants this is a ruse through and
through okay number one Donald Trump
framed this entire offer as it being a
good thing even from his perspective
that three years of relief and three
years of extension for TPS and for daca
recipients respectively would be part of
the deal if those are obviously good and
moral things
why did Trump take them away in the
first place and number two why is Trump
now offering them as what the other side
gets in other words if Donald Trump
agrees that everybody should be pleased
about the extension for daca recipients
and the extension to temporary protected
status why is it that those are the
things he's willing to give up if
they're good why isn't he saying that he
wants them as opposed to having taken
them away and now offering to give them
back only if we give him money for the
border wall that doesn't make any sense
but the real big issue here for me Pat
is that there's no path to citizenship
here for the daca recipients that's the
real issue because Republicans know that
they are not going to be able to weather
the political consequences of starting
to deport kids who were brought here by
their parents who were undocumented
immigrants that's not gonna fly for
Republicans and they know it so the idea
here of playing coy as if this is some
big concession even though it doesn't
actually include a path to citizenship
it is a complete and total ruse and I
support Democrats rejecting this offer
but the fact that Trump is even making
an offer that will make him look good in
the eyes of many I do think that we're
getting closer here to a compromise and
it may be something like three billion
dollars for the wall in exchange for
permanent protection for daca recipients
that may be something that I can get
behind I just I wonder if Trump is
willing to back off that 5.7 billion
dollar number for the wall I don't know
where he came up with that but he seems
to be pretty glued to it
yeah I'm quite frankly not married to no
money for the wall if what's offered is
actually really good because remember
the border wall is going to take much
longer than Donald Trump is going to be
in office to actually build and even
though 5.7 billion or 3 billion is Pat
is suggesting these are insane amounts
of money right the the the amount of
stuff that you could do with that amount
of money is truly stunning so I'm not
pretending like because it's the
government billions don't matter but if
3 billion were to be authorized in
exchange for permanent status for daca
recipients that permanent status would
be a really really big deal and even the
authorization of the 3 billion which
would in the end probably go using
Trump's math for about a hundred and
fifty miles of border fence or steel
barrier or whatever much of which would
clearly not end up being built because
of the slowness with which it would
actually take place I would be open to
that I am not ideologically opposed to a
single dollar for the wall if what's
being offered actually makes sense and
of course what Trump in his first offer
made available doesn't make any sense in
it's a total ruse and he's also making
totally misleading claims about what the
impact of it would be Donald Trump is
claiming that the border wall would cut
drugs and undocumented crossings by 50%
I mean that's impossible mathematically
remember that only a third of all
undocumented entries are even happening
via the border most of the drugs are
coming through ports of entry not
through spots and the border where a
border wall would be placed so the
claims as to how it would work are
completely wrong the offer is a
completely bogus ruse Democrats should
reject it and they should insist for the
time being on no money for the wall we
will negotiate on that once government
is open trump is increasingly in an
untenable position and that's actually a
good thing for democrats and nancy
pelosi's approval numbers keep climbing
and climbing Donald Trump's keep
dropping and dropping from the low 40s
now back into the high 30s and they've
been there for a couple of weeks this is
not such an amazing deal from Democrat
for Democrats that they are in apparel
position by rejecting it in fact Nancy
Pelosi's approval rating has been doing
really well given how she's been
standing up to President Trump the wall
is something that low information people
can very easily get behind they can
pretend that it would be effective they
can pretend that it's the big alpha male
accomplishment for Donald Trump but
let's not allow him to do it unless the
offer is serious and if daka's what's on
the table there has to be some kind of
permanent status I you know I don't want
the wall I don't think it's effective I
don't think we would be wasting money on
it but I actually would be open to some
funding for the wall if Democrats can
get something serious on daca permanent
status and then lastly by the way to go
back to what Trump wants which is 1.6
billion for humanitarian aid and
drug-drug technology drove stopping
drugs from coming over nearly 3,000 new
law enforcement and border officials and
75 new judge teams for the party of
small government that's a pretty massive
expansion of government and I'm not
saying we don't need more judge teams we
actually do one of the reasons that
people are staying for such long periods
of time in these detention situations on
the border is that the immigration
courts are functioning really slowly
because they are not nearly as well
staffed as they should be so I'm in
favor of that but the idea that what
Trump wants is such a massive expansion
of government seems to have gone
completely unnoticed or deliberately
ignored by the so called small
government conservatives my question to
you do you think that Democrats should
accept this offer which supposedly Mitch
McConnell is going to bring up for a
vote in the Senate this week or do you
agree with me that as it stands right
now it should be rejected send me your
thoughts the show is on Instagram a
David Pakman show I'm on Instagram at
David Pakman follow us there poll
upcoming about what you think Democrats
should do we have a child in the Oval
Office not a president and we have
actually a child with
particularly poor attention span we've
already learned many times that Donald
Trump is watching TV all the time but
there's now a report out that Donald
Trump once just walked out of a meeting
with Paul Ryan to go watch television in
his private dining room this is back
when Republican Congressman Paul Ryan
was Speaker of the House and he went to
the Oval Office and he was explaining to
Donald Trump what the Republican health
care bill proposal had in it and Trump
according to a former White House
communications deputy communications
director Paul Ryan went on for about 15
minutes and this is according to cliff
Sims and Trump sat there sipping on his
diet cokes and sort of looking around
and eventually Donald Trump just got up
and walked out of the room and went to
his private dining room and turned on
the TV and just started watching
television and Mike Pence was also in
the meeting Mike Pence had to go over
and grab Trump and convince him to come
back to the Oval Office to finish his
meeting with Paul Ryan and this is a
sort of interesting and notable anecdote
but it's not surprising it's not hard to
believe it's exactly what we've been
hearing from anybody who knows Trump's
routine as we've learned about it and
what I am thinking back to is how Barack
Obama had to work so much harder than a
normal President to overcome all of
these hypocritical attacks from
Republicans the smears about Obama being
a foreign communist socialist Muslim
Indonesian and all that stuff Obama was
staying up late reading reports getting
up early reading books day night all the
time
Trump arguably hasn't read anything his
entire presidency we've learned that he
gets this bogus presidential daily
briefing with a couple bullet points in
a picture or two on it he doesn't read
books he doesn't listen to staffers he
doesn't often even listen to other
elected officials as we're learning
Barack Obama was slammed for his
relatively modest vacation days and then
Trump setting records in terms of the
number of days he's taking off and the
cost of those golf trips it contradicts
what Trump said he would do during the
campaign he said he'd be at the White
House all the time he'd be working
working with no brakes and Republicans
don't even care that he's doing the
exact
and I was thinking about this and you
know the obvious double standard and
there is a really big one but you can't
even talk to Republicans about double
standards anymore if you bring up the
double standard of trumps vacation time
if you bring up the double standard of
Trump exploding the deficit while
claiming he would fix it and criticizing
others for the debt and deficit or
whatever else there's a deeper problem
here which is that even if you can point
out a double standard on a particular
issue much of the American right has
bought into the idea that problems
aren't complex that problems are simple
and that the solutions are simple and
that you don't really need a president
who studies and reads and consults and
learns they have bought in hook line and
sinker to the idea that you just need
someone with the right seven word
talking point build a wall band trans
people from the military bail on Syria
cut taxes and Obama care whatever it is
and when you believe that solutions are
as simple as the American right believes
that they are you no longer care about
double standards by the president you no
longer care about a president who
doesn't read or spend time learning
about any of these issues and that's it
okay
it's a worldview that's not based in
reality and it underlies this entire
sort of small government [ __ ]
presidents are okay Industrial Complex
which we saw first with George W Bush
that was nothing compared to what we're
seeing under Donald Trump Bush at least
read the wrong stuff I'm not
romanticizing george w bush but at least
he read and listened to advisors they
were horrible right-wing neocon Warhawk
advisors but he at least handled this in
a more reasonable way in the back of
this there is this underlying issue of
Republicans buying this ruse that the
solutions are always really simple and
also when you hear that Donald Trump is
just wandering out to go watch TV I mean
that's the type of thing you think about
when you are aware of someone's
cognitive decline
so this of course continuing to raise
more questions and concerns for people
on the Left people in the middle and on
the right who are sort of connected to
the realities of what we should expect
from a president but if you believe that
all the answers are simple and you think
that as long as you've got the right
single talking point nothing else
matters you're probably not going to be
hugely concerned by this revelation I
really struggled with how to cover the
story of a group of Magha hat-wearing
Trump supporting high school students
from Covington Kentucky who surrounded
and mocked a Native American military
veteran at a Washington DC rally because
at first I saw posts on Twitter and
Facebook about how the only perpetrators
here were the entitled smirking
privileged mostly white anti-abortion
Catholic school kids and how it was
wrong that they surrounded this Native
American protester in this intimidating
way I also started seeing posts with a
very different perspective which was the
kids did nothing wrong the problem was
that there was instigation not only by
Nathan Phillips the Native American
military veteran who was singing and
playing a drum but also by so-called
black Muslims who were not actually
black Muslims and we'll get to that a
little bit later and that actually these
kids should be applauded for not
becoming violent when they were
approached by a very hostile crowd the
truth is neither of those extremes and
we are now fortunately getting some more
nuance on the story and I know that
probably everyone will be upset with me
for my understanding of the story but as
I've always done on the program I'm not
going to give you anything other than my
honest and genuine perspective so let's
get into it
this all happened after an indigenous
peoples march and an anti-abortion March
both in Washington DC sort of collided
okay and I could focus on the coarsening
of the culture under Trump I could talk
about education as the catalyst here or
violence we could make it about racism
and xenophobia we could make it about
Catholic schools and parenting and
social class and entitlement and it
would be a story about all of those
things but this one
actually mostly is a story about toxic
partisan politics combined with elements
of all of that other stuff this is the
last show that would be caught doing the
both sides are to blame thing when
that's not actually the case okay when
it comes to take your pick fake news
it's not both sides the right is
overwhelmingly the perpetrator and
perpetuator of fake news when it comes
to voter suppression it's not both sides
it's the right that has figured out that
they benefit from fewer people voting
and it's mostly almost exclusively the
right it's trying to hold down the boat
but I went back and I took a look at
this nearly two-hour video of the
incident in Washington DC and there is
no shortage of blame to go around here
for what went on and what's really
important here is that one person or
groups wrongs don't justify anyone elses
wrongs here this is not a defense of
these maggot wearing kids and we'll get
to that but the point is the story that
the only thing to comment on here is
these maggot at wearing kids who were
standing around a Native American
protester is simply wrong and even the
New York Times which is no bastion of
right-wing conspiracy theories is saying
that the full video part of which we're
playing now for people tells a very
different story than just that initial
piece of the video that went viral the
initial piece that went viral was a
Native American military veteran Nathan
Phillips beating a drum and singing
surrounded by a group of young mostly
white teenagers that looked like they
came not from an anti-abortion rally but
from a Trump rally where they spent all
of their allowance money on Trump
apparel and hats right and in fact in
the video you see at one point that one
of the kids is standing about 12 inches
from Nathan Phillips is faced with this
ludicrous smirk that was at first the
only part of the video that got
attention and it should have gotten
attention because these kids are
standing around one
in a way that looks intimidating they're
entitled smirks should piss anyone off
it certainly pissed me off their school
is investigating what took place the
school says they'll take appropriate
action these are kids who also are
pictured in other stories that have come
out about them at a basketball game for
example against a mostly black team
screaming at the black players some of
them had painted their entire bodies
basically instead of black face it was
like a black body there's every
indication that these kids are
extraordinarily annoying entitled
ignorant clowns enabled by their parents
teachers chaperones whoever else's
around them that is a story here but to
pretend that they simply showed up
looking for trouble while no one else
was misbehaving and there were no other
factors here would be wrong and I'm not
going to do that first of all there are
numerous disputes about how they even
ended up in the same spot as the Native
American protester here there were also
pro-choice people who were not behaving
perfectly here there are reports that
indigenous peoples protestors were
yelling go back to Europe to these white
kids that's actually on video that's
insane and that needs to be denounced
there was a group of they were called by
some people black Muslims but they're
not they're black Israelites who were
proselytizing in the very very
inflammatory way that they do yelling at
everybody including at these kids they
if you're not familiar with the black
Israelites they're a group of black
Americans who claims that they are the
true descendants of the Israelites and
sort of in a sense the real Jews
although there's sort of a crossover
group between being Jews and Christians
but really what they're known for is
being inflammatory Street Preachers
which they chose to do at a central
point between two conflicting political
rallies reports include that the black
Israelites started arguing with the
maggot kids they were reportedly calling
them child molested [ __ ] dirty ass
crackers demon animal
future school shooters and racist
bastards and at a certain point in all
of this Nathan Phillips shows up when
the black Israelites are taunting the
kids and he walks into the crowd of
students choosing to do this he could
have opted to walk in a different way
from the video that I saw Nathan
Phillips walked up to the kids and the
kids just stood there there are people
reporting that there were chants of
build the wall against the indigenous
peoples that's disgusting and that of
course proves that the border wall has
never actually been about border
security because if it were you wouldn't
be yelling that at Native Americans it's
about xenophobia and racism and it's
vile but the problem I have with this
Pat is that it became an Internet mob
with people cherry picking out of a
two-hour video trying to identify some
of these underage kids who of course
bear significant responsibility
themselves but also our kids they're the
product of their parents where were the
chaperones why did the school allow them
to go to an anti-choice rally dress like
they're coming from a trump rally so I'm
not here to rank who did the worst thing
or to say who's more to blame and I'm
not saying that everyone is equally to
blame but what's clear to me is that I
can't think of anyone who behaved
particularly appropriately here and I am
with you and being disgusted with the
maggot kids I am with you and being
disgusted by everything we're learning
about things that have taken place at
basketball games and their behavior but
we can't pretend that that they were the
unique and sole instigators here and
there were certainly a bunch of
misunderstandings when you take a look
at even that entire two-hour clip you
may not come away knowing exactly what
happened because it's just not the best
video quality not the best audio quality
one thing I will point out though is
it's unclear that Nathan Phillips went
when he walked up to those those group
of kids like I don't know if they
necessarily thought that he was being
combative or what he was trying to do
because they responded like it was some
sort of pep rally like it was like maybe
Nathan Phillips was like playing along
with them I don't know I think you have
to kind of give the kids that
and out on that one because I don't know
if they realize if they were being
offensive or if the situation was going
to escalate but certainly the
responsibility does not bear solely on
them I know that there are people on the
Left who are going to be mad at me how
dare I question the initial narrative
how dare I question the narrative that
places blame only on the kids I think
that these kids are vile quite frankly
and the more we learn about other things
that have happened involving their
school it's absolutely horrible but we
we need to be full in our reporting and
I think in the long run everybody loses
by pushing a narrative that's
increasingly demonstrably false based on
the video if you disagree with me I do
want to hear from you I have a truly
extraordinary turn of events to tell you
about today the plans which according to
our president and to his lawyer Rudy
Giuliani
and many other people simply didn't
exist for Trump Tower Moscow have been
found and not only do plans exist they
even include the idea of bribing Russian
President Vladimir Putin with a
penthouse apartment worth 50 million
dollars in implicitly exchange for
allowing the project to go forward as
planned and this is such an incredible
situation and such a turn of events that
it's almost cartoonish in a sense I mean
the degree to which the reality differs
from the story that we have gotten from
the president and the people surrounding
him could not be more different for
months or even longer at this point
probably a year or more since the Trump
Tower Moscow issue has been sort of
floating around we've been told that
Trump Tower Moscow was basically nothing
right it was mentioned okay but Trump
himself wasn't thinking about it he
wasn't working on it he certainly wasn't
directing anyone including his lawyer
Michael Cohen to do much to push forward
the project of Trump Tower Moscow it was
more or less a silly pipe dream would
have been nice to do if it worked out
but essentially no Trump Organization
energy beyond a couple phone calls maybe
or an email
and there were put together and were
actions that were taken we were led to
believe that it was more of a we'll look
into it
but nothing actually happened at all
ever and as we heard many times there
were certainly no physical plans for the
building at all nothing specific this
project was effectively a notion buried
deep in the mind of some small number of
people in Donald Trump's organization
period one of the people fomenting that
narrative is Donald Trump's television
attorney Rudy Giuliani who said to the
new yorker just about 48 hours ago that
quote no plans were ever made there were
no drafts nothing in the file that's a
direct quote from Rudy Giuliani and as I
mentioned yesterday Rudy Giuliani is a
lawyer but he is really serving as
Trump's public propagandist lawyer he's
not making legal statements but will
still evaluate that statement on its
merits no plans were ever made there
were no drafts nothing in the file
except that in their second blockbuster
this week BuzzFeed news it's not
BuzzFeed it's BuzzFeed News has obtained
the plans for Trump Tower Moscow they
exist they existed they were created and
those plans and text messages and emails
even outline how radomir Putin would be
effectively bribed into going along with
the project with a penthouse worth an
estimated 50 million dollars BuzzFeed
News has obtained hundreds of pages of
documents and emails and text messages
and even architectural plans and a whole
bunch of other stuff we have a rendering
of what Trump Tower Moscow was set to
look like we had also the indication
that it would be 1,500 and well it would
be taller than 1516 feet tall which was
the height of the lakhta Center in st.
Petersburg comparing it to other notable
world buildings including the
Commerzbank Tower
Frankford and the Eiffel Tower and the
shard in London here's a rendering of
what this particular building would have
looked like in Moscow you can see it in
the context of the Moscow skyline with
the Moscow River in the background
here's a rendering of the atrium inside
Trump Tower Moscow complete with a view
again of the Moscow River out the
windows of the building and you might be
saying well if they knew that you could
see the Moscow River out the windows did
they know where the building would go
yes they did we have a map that is part
of these documents which includes the
proposed development site for the
building again right on the Moscow River
with an amazing beautiful view of
presidency district and it turns out
that it's not just a couple of
renderings there were already
architectural plans by September of 2015
the plans laid out how Trump Tower
Moscow would be a glass obelisk it would
be 100 stories tall with this sort of
diamond like shape at the top that if
you've been watching with us you saw in
the images we showed you already not
only were their plans the plans had also
been sent to the Russian develop their
developer that was engaged to actually
do the construction that's Andrew Roz
off he indicated he was ready to get
started on this project and there is
also as Rudy Giuliani did admit there is
this finalized letter of intent signed
by Donald Trump from about a month after
the architectural plans had been filed
and that includes that this building
would contain 250 luxury condos in the
tower 15 floors of hotel with 150 hotel
rooms there would be a spa there would
be a fitness center there would be a
commercial space as well as what is
called Class A office space in the
United States or more upscale luxury
type office space the letter of intent
even specifies that Donald Trump would
be paid four million bucks up front he
would then get 25% when the licensing
agreement is executed 25% when the
location is finalized and the other half
of that four million based on some
their milestones Trump would get a cut
of condo sales he would get a management
fee for 25 years he would get profit
sharing from the hotel and then after
all of that which already tells us it
wasn't just a nothing notion that Trump
wasn't at all involved in and that
nobody was taking seriously there were
architectural plans there were licensing
fees and future profit streams all I
laid out there then we get to the gift
to Putin for going along with all of
this the top of the building was slated
to have a penthouse apartment the market
value would be roughly 50 million
dollars and as previously reported by
BuzzFeed news the plan was to give that
away for free to Vladimir Putin just to
have himself this was not just an idea
in a trump staffers mind because to law
enforcement officials have confirmed
that Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer
personally discussed gifting the
penthouse to Vladimir Putin with an aide
to Putin's press secretary and it could
have even gone further than that we just
aren't sure yet this is what we call a
bribe okay Russian oligarch Felix aider
who is working with Trump on this and
was a key player in the Trump Russia
probe is on record saying quote my idea
was to give a 50 million dollar
penthouse to Putin and to charge 250
million more for the rest of the units
all the oleg arks would line up to live
in the same building as Putin Seder was
involved in gifting the penthouses to
Putin Michael Cohen was involved in
discussions about that and aid to
Putin's press secretary was involved in
that discussion and then we get to the
degree of involvement that Donald Trump
may or may not have had Donald Trump has
denied having any interests in Russia
he's denied being in regular contact
with anybody about this project but
BuzzFeed who did their homework on this
can now report that Donald Trump
received at least 10 updates about the
project that they know of specifically
and of course in all of this is the
allegation that Trump directed Michael
Cohen
to lie to Congress about it on the basis
of that BuzzFeed news report from a few
days ago the cherry on top this tweet
from Trump
in 2013 directed at Arras a gala Rove I
had a great weekend with you and your
family you have done a fantastic job
Trump Tower Moscow is next Amin was Wow
Ameen as I believe I Ross's son and was
involved in that
Trump Tower meeting that took place in
2016 so what's next it's going to be
what Rudy Giuliani's saying of course we
had plans it's a real estate deal you
need plans but so what making plans
isn't a crime licensing agreements
aren't crimes gifting penthouses to
presidents of foreign countries to get
deals approved that's not a crime this
is just business and then the next day
Rudy will tell us that was a
hypothetical statement that I made that
wasn't a legal statement I was
hypothetically quoting myself as Trump's
attorney but it was just hypothetical it
wasn't real and of course it would also
be wrong because there is this thing
called the Foreign Corrupt Practices Act
of 1977 it's also called fcpa and it
very specifically has anti bribe
provisions regarding using money or
things of value to influence or obtain
authorization for or promises from
foreign officials in their official
capacity so for everybody saying there's
nothing here this is merely a
businessman Trump trying to build a
tower that's not true there are a lot of
issues here it might violate the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act it would be
indicative of the fact that Donald Trump
was not telling the truth about his
involvement here all along there are all
sorts of different crimes potentially
tied up in this the penthouse was a
thing of value offering it to Putin to
get an advantage in terms of permitting
and going forward with the project could
indeed be criminal and then lastly the
other potentially criminal element here
this project was set to receive funding
from the VTB Bank in Russia VTB Bank at
the time that these discussions were
going on was under sanctions by the
United States of America which makes the
financing of Trump Tower Moscow
we now know did have architectural plans
it makes the fine the financing
potentially illegal as well so what will
they say will they say the BuzzFeed
report is simply wrong because every
time they do that BuzzFeed comes out
with more document documentary evidence
about this will they say well Coen acted
alone he's a liar and a convicted felon
does anybody believe for a moment that
Donald Trump would be not involved in
the plans to build the biggest building
in Europe including the gift of a 50
million dollar penthouse to Vladimir
Putin when 9/11 happened Trump went on
TV and bragged as a result of 9/11 and
the Twin Towers being knocked down his
building is now the tallest in lower
Manhattan does anybody believe that a
guy who does that that that's what he
thinks of when the Twin Towers are
knocked down by foreign terrorists does
anyone believe he wouldn't be involved
in the building of the tallest building
in Europe which was set to have his name
on it every single lie here is falling
apart let me know your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter a David Pakman show there's
something that is being widely reported
about Rudy Giuliani which would Simon
simultaneously sort of be the most
sensible explanation as to what's going
on but also very very sad let me set it
up for you so we've been talking for a
while now about how Rudy Giuliani's
television appearances to defend
president Trump are legally incoherent
but they don't really need to be legally
coherent because Rudy Giuliani is
Trump's lawyer only in the most general
sense he's not making legal statements
for Donald Trump on television
so when Giuliani says there were no
mistress payments but then says there
were and Trump didn't know about them
and wasn't involved in them and then
says actually Trump did know about them
and was involved in them but it's fine
it's completely legal or when Giuliani
says I've heard the tapes and then says
there are no tapes or when Giuliani says
there was no collusion and later he
denies ever having said that there was
no collusion
legally it's of limited importance
according to most legal experts but it's
very strange so we've been speculating
that maybe this is some kind of
calculated 4d chess strategy you put out
conflicting stories you make it
impossible to even know what it is
Giuliani is claiming are the facts it's
possible that it's just incompetence on
rudy giuliani's behalf but now it's
being reported that the explanation
might be way simpler than this and it's
called alcohol it's called drinking
there's a number of Trump allies who are
now saying that there is huge concern at
the White House about Giuliani's strange
television appearances and that they
believe at least part of the problem is
that Rudy's going on TV after drinking
and I guess by this it follows logically
drinking enough for the drinking to
affect what he says and how he says it
on television there are three White
House officials and Republicans close to
the White House none of whom were
authorized to speak publicly about this
for obvious reasons who are telling the
same story which is that number one
Trump is frustrated that Rudy Giuliani
really messed up the recent rebuttals to
the buzz BuzzFeed news Robert Muller
controversy no one is suggesting that
Trump is thinking about firing Rudy
Giuliani at least at this point but what
keeps coming up is this topic of alcohol
and it appears that allies of Trump are
suggesting Rudy shouldn't be allowed on
TV at night like this is actually a
discussion that Rudy Giuliani can keep
doing TV appearances but they shouldn't
happen at night because he's going on TV
after drinking and three different
sources have said this at this point and
the entire thing reminds me of when
former Trump aide remember Sam Nunn Berg
he went on TV and his behavior was
extraordinarily erratic and at one point
CNN's Erin Burnett smelled alcohol on
his breath
remember this insane moment on CNN
doctor earlier about what people in the
White House were saying about you yeah I
don't know whether you you were you were
drinking or on drugs or whatever they
what had happened today I'm talking to
you yeah I have smelled alcohol on your
breath well I had a drink you haven't
had a drink so that's not no so I I just
because it is the talk out there
I know it's awkward let me just get give
you the question category no I have not
anything else
no no no besides my meds okay
antidepressants is that okay no I mean
I'm not I'm just trying to understand
well look well look they take I'd love
to see that question put to Rudy
Guiliani and it actually has come up
before back in May he was asked about
his drinking by Politico and he said he
sometimes likes to have a drink with
dinner that he likes drinking when he
smokes cigars and actually alcohols the
most reasonable explanation to explain
why Rudy Guiliani one day this week
quoted Donald Trump and then the next
day called it a hypothetical quote that
didn't actually exist all the other
explanations that point to incompetence
or some kind of advanced strategy or
cognitive decline or whatever
drinking alcohol actually doesn't
require any of that speculation and in a
sense it's the simplest explanation of
all what do you think is behind his
weird behavior alcohol a strategy of
sorts incompetence confusion send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on twitter at david
pakman show Rudy Giuliani Trump's
so-called
lawyer but really as I mentioned a
television PR lawyer not a lawyer who's
gonna do stuff in court for Trump makes
one statement then he walks it back he
calls it a hypothetical quote of the
president he says he really doesn't know
he's just getting up to speed on the
facts we've heard that from Rudy before
the latest example of this is as I
already told you in the first story
today he said in a January 20th New York
Times interview that Donald Trump told
him there were Trump Tower Moscow
discussions going on quote from the day
I announced till the day I won the next
day yesterday January 21st as I already
told you Rudy Giuliani walks it back and
he says no no no that was a hypothetical
quote it wasn't an actual quote of what
Donald Trump told me it was a
hypothetical quote which of course makes
no grammatical sense and it makes no
material sense it makes no sense of any
kind okay very strange walk back so then
the New Yorker gets a hold of Rudy
Giuliani and asks
about the walk back because it's so
strange and Rudy Guiliani unprovoked
starts talking about tapes which as far
as we knew didn't even exist
check out the transcript of this
interview with The New Yorker and Rudy
Giuliani Giuliani says I guess the but
BuzzFeed story I don't remember what it
said about Cohen but it said there was
corroboration that the president talked
to Cohen and told him to lie about I
guess it was the Moscow proposal there
are no tapes there are no texts
there is no corroboration that the
president told him to lie I can tell you
from the moment I read the story I knew
the story was false because I have been
through all the tapes I have been
through all the texts I have been
through all the emails and I knew none
existed to which The New Yorker
obviously says wait what tapes have you
gone through because we're not aware of
any such tapes and Rudy Giuliani says I
shouldn't have said tapes they alleged
there were texts and emails that
corroborated what Cohen was saying the
president told him to lie there were no
texts there were no emails and the
president never told him to lie well I
have listened to tapes but none of them
concern this can anyone really be this
dumb or is it possible that Pat's right
which is that this is just idiots E as a
strategy the idea being that Giuliani is
a lawyer
only in that he has a law degree but for
Trump he's a PR guy on TV and as a PR
guy on TV he's not actually trying to
make a legal argument he's not stating
what the president's legal position is
on any of this stuff
he is not even really trying to appeal
to the rational audience he's trying to
keep Trump's base engaged and reasonably
giving some plausible deniability that
they can say we don't think Trump
actually did anything wrong so he's
going out there and deliberately so in
confusion he says eh and then he says
the opposite of a and it's all to muddy
the waters it's all to make it
impossible to actually know what's going
on and to keep the Trump is relatively
happy that everything's fine and Trump
is just a great guy the part that's
difficult for me to believe about that
is that I just don't think Giuliani's
are good enough actor to this fluidly or
this genuinely seemed as though he
actually spoke mistakenly like if this
was planned to now float the idea of
tapes and then immediately say I didn't
mean that there actually aren't any
tapes I just don't think the guys are
good enough actor to pull it off
isn't that where the term useful idiot
comes from like maybe he doesn't realize
that he's playing that role he's
genuinely trying to do a good job but he
keeps falling flat on his face and they
realized the administration does that
this is good for them and that's why
they keep him going and that well the
important thing with that idea again is
none of Rudy Giuliani's media interviews
are assertions about Trump's legal
position at a matter is in terms of what
he's telling Robert Moeller for example
this is just Rudy running his mouth on
TV it's not legally binding in that
sense but if tapes genuinely exist we've
suspected that for some time now the
question becomes will we ever actually
get access to them so this could be
idiocy
it could be deliberately planting
conflicting stories but importantly it's
only incidentally relevant what Rudy
Giuliani says from a legal standpoint
the question were left with is do the
tapes exist what do you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the shows on Twitter
at D Pakman we'll take a David Pakman
show
rather we'll take a quick break and be
back after this